ご紹介いただきました
業界人らしくですね大天使のお話をさせて頂ければと
a
まず
これは皆様ご存知かと思いますけれども
あとも切れ誤認してまいりました東京オリンピック同様お母さんになりますが
これは公式のポスターがありましてその中にと思って出し
んですね
弁護側が全面に回っていますん
そもそもですね
まあ昔からの頃おもてなしという言葉はあのー
そうだしているわけですけれどこれが非常に大きくですね世界を取り上げられていて
世界はのそうな
しているようなエロ度も見守っていません
you
ルークいいんですね
方が増えてきましたひっかけまでして覚えてらっしゃいません
2013年上のサイズです
他の所はですね1点を守って歌詞というです
言葉を合わせから入りましています
ああいう子からですけれども
やっぱ私たちはなくな日常点検もそのを照らして言う
いうことはあっ
意識をするで消費時に私たちの事実だ
表らしいビジネスも悪いのではあるん
一つだホテルが代表例だ
公募てらしいですねひろに実は曖昧でね
何かこの時期だからこそ最後ですね侵略からもうちょっと振り返っておきたいというの
は今日も私のテーマで
ん
皆さん是非今からいただきた
ありません
一般的やですね皆さんの皆様方ロードしてももう頭の中にそう思ってほしいと言うとし
て
部分が非常に大きく
フィーチャーされてるんじゃないかとですこれはどういうことかっていうと
まずは心遣い
来年に対する孤独お小遣いこれは実際ですね
こういったようなラリーとを代えて浅野
らりん対する法図解が低いジャパンよっておもてなしその最上位にを照らし学位
まあ選びんローズんですけれど方
まぁ実際これはもう
おもてなしをコンサルタントしているような形が殺さかに使って本を書いていますし
教えてる場面も多々あろうかと思いますが実はですね私が考えている
おもてなしなこれでは本当に不十分で
a
これはですね新契約でそのう
パッチ年あいけないとわけですけれどもそれで圧迫十分ある
ねえそれではどういうことなのかということなんですけれども
後半へ辛いとして私はここに狂う
もどって来る
これは
日本語ですね茶道家がこうもも照らしてもらったスタートして言って黒子んとやべ理解
しないと思う
いけないというふうに思いますどうしてもその
イメージ的では
気配り心配りというようなところばかりだったり言われることも多いんですけど
僧侶ん
これはですねブレーカーしてみると明確にですね日本は3本かどうおもてなしの電気の
新曲は決まっていますそれをなんで構成されているかそれということですね
こういうことだと思います
a 3つの要素
学校の車へいうところはワインならどちらか急便な皆さんはやっぱり頭の中でそれぞれ
の3強とフィラメントで解説したような
ところですねすればもっとまーた n
行動ぬんです
具体的には体がお
まよくホテルはからマリオしか不要な力でますけど絵がポンポンしゃべらさを貼って
ありましたが
愛咲挨拶
心がし
お声がけ1払って言って
大字会きちんとした言葉遣いが
ではなくてもちろん踏まえ大切なんですがそうではなくてですね私がやっぱり忘れて
いけないのは
あとの2つ方ですね真戸祭り活動再開を
診療したかおもてなしでお客様に合ったいっ
豪華車両ができられん
映画そのしつらいの部分以外なんですけど室内のこと
これは用意とか準備往復までですがもてなすための快適な環境
心地よい空間作る分かりやすい教示
ありまえん
ひぁっにしろ a
控え室の方で私もを控えしている通してくれた人
影響太田を用意してくれました
パープレーとをよろしく最終的なスケールを
見せてくれる大型紙も実は私に対して
今日生きてる皆様だと話して太田真実はしてるんですよ
これ用意
準備というところが非常に大切なところでホール実はめだかないんですけどなおざりに
なりやすい
所なので方はぜひ覚える
ていますじゃあそれは私たちの生活の中で私が所属しているチームでグループで
学校で企業で地域で何ができるの
というようなことをしてはならない後ろに対しですか
パートは語相違という
3台がない感を覚えることをするならばいって大臣賞に出したらこういった所ですで
大切なを持ってほしいんだ
これは自分自身がさを綺麗に飾るということではなくて相手に対して気持ちを過ごしい
たためも
みなるんだ
ウエア
輸入品であったりといったことある
そもそもちゃん世界+ね小さな暗がりの者4社のなかで100純およびする主画素を
検証する
その時の装いという方は100人運命だってはいけない
ただし失礼のない非常に新風を用意して性別にそれを着て
社長兵士で放火し言う
のことですねさあどんなにこういう
4細くしている0されています
具体的にですねこれをですね
皆さんもう少し噛み砕いてまた店舗てなんだか振れたことがあるかも
したいんですが
これは
まあモーションホテルだけではなくてですけどが降る前のところ皆様方はれている
イメージできると思う先ほどちょっと強調した2番目3番目がしつらえと予想する
ところ
ついて共著を出していきたいです
れ出来の
これはまあこの巨大
候補しもちろんホテルたらしい公園もあるし何なんですから
俺は
排泄なおもてなし0なんですね
これは立っています加工も図柄なぁされた声で笑った
なんということです
月桃クラブなんですよねこれは
言語は違うとしても世界過去
これを見れば何かここは何をすればそうかん
すぐわかります
ポーテープとブランドスタートという
思うんですよ
いつどこでスタートしたご存知の方いらっしゃいますか
これは第1回などです第1回東京オリンピックの時に資産
ん
チェーンログイン
一方が変わりません
世界ファンポークの
弦をそのトイレのは前張ることないと無理ですよね
僕のため8か国であるわけですから
それと共に表示するのでいけない
そこで考えたら1本
1本焼酎
準備委員から考えていますあして10人ぐらいのデザイン中だったその中で有名なを
目指すれたんだろうこうただみさこ
そのチームですねもう数ヶ月で買えるんだったらということで頑張ってこの
ピクトグラムというのはみなさんへ
これは今おっしゃらないでそれをするこれ大切な思ってらっしゃるんですよ
室内分
というよう
あとはタント l です
俺もそうですねこれは
私たちは私の働いているというかステーションホテル
そう
ちょっとちっちゃいんですがこれは私たちローラーズがマートン距離でバーレイ社
仲良く
ホテルが入ってい
大
中央再評価あるところが
ラベル等ベアなっていましてアトリウムという昔は誰だろうこういうさん発見校訓
屋根裏部屋ないですか
昔あのにも使ってなかったところですねお客さん専用
ご宿泊のお客様性もゲスラージアトリームということ
そして大にご宿泊のた専用
朝食をご提供する7人もん
諸侯のを暗唱なんですけど
エアー様ですね朝食の場合
影響をさせていただいています非常にいろんな食べれないと言う
東京の各ホテル考えどうかん
を
その中の1信頼ですねこれがあり思ってるだけ
も
岡山したは今まだ紅葉がありますよねをフレッシュオレンジとか
輸入とか言ってやる側に思い立ってそれを守るため
グラスです
グラサンとも言われています猫からとってはから注いでということですこれがなぜ
表足ならかわかりますか
方グラスのレイアウトショップ見えてくれます
大外もお客様ってないなぁと言いません
化粧すると方向がカラッとなっていておくだけ登ってしまう
でそうするとあとエヴァせ持ち低い方であったりと
ひょっとしたらお子様がいらっしゃったりとかした場合には非常に入り取りづらくなら
北志賀暗さの僕ない
うそうではなくて常にやっぱり球を使っているして取りやすいように暗さの場合運動さ
せる
で or 式前てるわけでしょ高
前のほうにあった集中させてい
いうことでただ単に取る者もブラスが置いてあればそれをおもてなししているという
こと
なくて高級なグラスがを怒られたそういうことではなくて
使いやすいようになっているか
便利な用具があっているか
それも大切な4つらいですそれはおもてなしなんですよ
からこんなものはそんな小さなことですかというふうに言われるからも多いからです実
はこれはやっぱり認識の方を覚えて
それおそらく私たちパって方点であるがやるべきことかな
噴火の知恵と思いました
はいあとはべ体現し辛いフライパン客室で
が張るどっちべきが目立ち最高鏡張りました
客室な写真ですけどお前等 the line 画質られ
色
外部的なところだと思うんですけど他清潔に便利
つかんやすいを考えて
データーたように
装飾品がーーーーーーーイんか大きなベッドを使っているかということだけなんですね
走行にきちんとしたパスピング形でもうすごい努力が
で清潔で快適で使いやすい
最高峰てな者です100出力いるんですけど私も立てる出張いただきます
人前台を大勢な召喚獣やピストホテルたんですよ
え私が来るお客さんアップルーを奉呈して一生懸命やってくれた補填
100し続ければ一発れ
どのまでケアしている
すごくわかっ
高校までにもまだが大変なんですけど
非常に処理県合同でして意識しだったんで
例えばの
[音楽]
ブーブーにバックラーし持ってんもう
夜例えば夜中に行った時に
ぶつからないで起きられるように足元と時の小さな小学校をつける
ホテルが多い理由でその4明日仕事とーまここてるスペシャホテルだから打ちにいき
ます
橋本がついておかあ地味系伝票が夜間
過ぎにされているそうですからその時に
もし日前っていうその単品建具やターンを聞いて
例えばスルーでちょっと水を見たいもしくはたらいいんじゃないか
いいなと思いましたらその時にこういう経験ありませんが
夜間で寝ていたちょっと起きた溝みたいなというふうに行きたいってればせるの電気を
つけたって
通常頭が100%の中に立ったものぞ
眩しくて目が覚めてしまって求めるにつけないということ
はありません想定されません
それは私はもどって来るの実は速ロールされていて真っ暗もし暮らしも投資家ついて
悩んで睡眠中だて前提に立ってそう bye にも芝スルー店東同笠た場合は中ちゃん
10%し明かりは派
いからそれ情報が入っ
た非常に柔らかいあかんで私めベットっても痩せられるそう言ってやるほどを実は本当
に見えないところです
サポートされていましてそれを放天大雪画質られると言う
あとはこれもすらよくいろんなところで
隠しかないですね東京して証を持っているが全長されるさえ覚えてるんですけど戻し
マヤ大王を上がりまして
10校対決は廊下部分ですあの
ブーバー4連覇で
ていた
パーターン制理想だけでなぜおもてなしになっているかということなんですけどよく
経営者だとホテルに行った時にホテルは客室の生主とするんだろうね
はもうカードっていっぱい子が出るませんか
バスターを
スローシャンプーリースをいっぱい入れたかごがそうだよくれません
それはですね私です実際出すと禁止していますん
アレアレ何がいいんですねもうすごくやっぱり景色がばうれしいがっかりしちゃうん
ですよ
引退際はチェッカーとしてますねあかんだよって脳は号
さーん並んでるもボコられると清掃に配属入れてくれるから感じがしちゃうんです
かぁーし
俺そこは絶対禁止ただ303俺もう申し訳ありません
そのカードを外に出さないという
なのでそういったところですねまぁ気を使って私たちはおもてなししようという
に代わっています
が最後ですよこれは実際にスタッフを
何かというと a
わかりますか俺はどうしてまだと思いますよね米ジョンさん
番号でそのソーキングのアレがあるんですが
ほっとくとですね皆さん寒いからあったかいかということカイジみたいな丘ちゃう
そうではなくて私たちはですね30秒をもらっていました手に入るんだ餡は30で決め
て下される
どっちしております
なのでやはりそれはよりフォーマルな感じ
いう本でお客さんからしてこれだってやっぱりどうしようが何か新しいがわかるんです
けどちょっとこれが買い付けを持ってくらしゃい
いう感触を
言うんだよマークは男性でいると予想
では皆さんホテルのホテルマンが異物が入っててほしいですから
誓いを知られるといいですかね
のこういう
ベルト付きスリッポンタイプチャイを選べる
こうだと買ったいいですかっ
それは当然報道かな
パンツでプレーンでまあうちモンストレッチってもいいんですけど
ヒモをの1日で浸透した貫通生えていた
良ければ幸あれん
それなところも火を使って皆さんが思ってますし
お迎えしたいということ
マッコイ点ほどですローソン大切な方てらっしゃいも採用さんじゃない遅い中に入って
いくということがでるかなんです
ブーバー市域頃だけど
だってできることがある
自分たちの住む街レディをきれいにするということだけど
5メートルということだけでも大切な大手の湿度はけれど
思いますぜひ機会ですね
自分たちができることを考えて
んですはいどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]